thank you
[Music]
so did you guys see that Mark Zuckerberg
won his first Jiu Jitsu competition I
heard about it some people were saying
it was rigged
why just because it's conspiracy
circling him always what we're using did
they let him win I haven't seen it you
think they let him win because he's Mark
Zuckerberg
I think sometimes if you compete against
a guy like you go in a competition and
you're like oh I'm just gonna compete
I'm a white belt I haven't done a
competition before
and then he looks across and the guy
who's gonna compete against him is
[__] Mark Zuckerberg that might be
like uh that might make somebody nervous
you know it may not compete as well just
because he's like [__] that's Mark
Zucker speaking as a dude who's done Jiu
Jitsu tournaments would that affect you
personally I think everything affects me
but do you think they'll let Mark like
as he's like as he's losing Whispers in
his ear like I'll give you a billion
dollars yeah that'd be time right now
then you yeah you [__] tap him so
let's do Lottery let's say that you
right if you matched up with against
Mark Zuckerberg
and he really did say hey just go easy
on me and I'll give you like a little
something
would that change anything in your
actions
[Laughter]
sell out
the tournament anyway is it's more for
yourself right yeah yeah you go out
there to test yourself unless you want
the [__] dinky little 20 medal then
yeah but what if Jeremy's on the side
going kill
get him yeah then I have to I have to
weigh out the pros and cons in my head
in the moment of like what I'm gonna do
he also didn't specify what a little
something was yeah okay though it's like
you don't want to lose to Mark
Zuckerberg though what if he goes if you
let me win I will give you a gold check
mark I'm like what is that
get that [__] like you only got it
because he he won it from Mark
Zuckerberg
dude but I only use instant
[Laughter]
Instagram two banners as well
I have a question though I think part of
me wants to beat up Mark Zuckerberg wow
like as a competitor you know what I
mean like you're gonna want to try to
beat him you don't want to lose him and
[__] that's okay I have a question
speaking of that do you think like
because Bart the other day was talking
about how he had to wrestle a blind guy
yeah in high school right do you think
like losing to Mark Zuckerberg is worse
or like equal to losing to another human
with a disability I think
it's not
I don't think it's equal yeah I don't
think it's equal because it's suckerberg
I think it's kind of our question look
just see him think
because I feel like he's going to the
whole match in his head yeah when I
really lose not because in my head I'm
like What's
what's the standard of competing with
somebody you know what I mean are you
more afraid of Mark Zuckerberg saying
hey
um
I'll give you some money if you'd let me
win or if he says if you don't let me
win see what happens
I I think I respond better to negative
reinforcement
so if you want me to get to do something
I'll be like yeah okay language I hear
you he just deletes Lighthouse
oh no that's cool
I think Colleen's yelling at me on the
sideline too [__] yeah
so he won the gold medal in the nogi
master one white belt featherweight
division is that impressive yeah what's
the organization is ibjf uh it just says
BJJ tour competition okay is that
yeah
no the fact that he wins that's pretty
cool look Mark Zuck is that Zuckerberg
is a winner dude this guy is pretty cool
he can also speak Chinese wow see
can you believe I'm trying to use I
don't even speak Chinese I can hardly
believe it how dare you I just I just
found out today that you're Chinese yeah
what do you think I was honestly I
thought you were some Southeast Asian
yeah because you're really dark I am
dark
so have you always been dark
just wait till it's always been your
thing wait till Sunday
from all the tournaments that you've
done just Jiu Jitsu yeah has have you
ever been intimidated by anything like
all the times like what just like so
I'll compete against a guy and I'll be
like that guy looks so scary has has a
guy ever like said something under his
breath that you like oh no like because
I think once you're in it you're in it
bro no one ever talks during those
matches like not everyone's pretty
friendly
are you allowed to talk they might they
might yell at you they might tell you to
like shut up they don't win they don't
whisper in your ear in the middle of
like a hole or something because I would
totally I haven't had that I would
totally whisper like like I'd probably
be half my game yeah you smell so good
yeah the strategy you would think in
some people or they fight and they
whisper things to mentally get you
because it's a mental game right yeah I
think so but I I just not really common
yet it might be in a couple years it
might be the new [__] thing that
everyone does yeah just imagine like
you're winning and then they say that
one thing I'm gonna kill you you don't
have a quote you're prepared for those
moments should I when your mouth just
ends up next to his ear yeah if you
don't say nothing you're gonna lose what
if it's like a simple little compliment
like
has anyone ever like when they announced
like like uh the match that you're in
has any of the announcers ever went like
uh Rick versus Nick
[Laughter]
I know that was a joke
I'm just preparing you for the world man
if that didn't happen what would you do
would you like
have some words Honestly though you're
probably just so locked in you don't
even like I care about that but at the
same time it's like
do you guys even haven't been to like a
real jiu jitsu tour like this is like a
regular tournament there's like big
matches like big events we'll go have
like a cool call out or whatever but
most of the time you're not giving your
name from it's just like a guy in a vest
like are you Nick Dunn and we're like
yeah come on okay you're this is your
bracket and then they walk over to the
mat something you guys compete and
there's is there it's so like yeah
multiple going on there's like eight
matches going on I have like a really
really good uh clip of me when I was was
entering like a bunch of breaking
tournaments and there was one where like
it was made up of a bunch of like known
guys and then I made the prelims so I
was in the bracket but I wasn't known
and then uh the clip is rude because the
MC when I come out is like uh I don't
know this guy's name but he's good uh
what's his name what is his name
what Ryan he thinks Ryan but you know
I'm full out dancing already
show it to show the actual clip to
people like oh yeah by the way some
guy's gonna be on the mic say he doesn't
know my name
the goal in life I hope one day you you
go to you're in a big match and then
Ryan's the announcer
that'd be awesome
dude yeah you know how to start laughing
by not saying anything in particular
just just doing everything verbatim
doing it right
it's gonna kill you to see me hey
everybody
that would Shatter Me
Like You didn't say hi to me right you
didn't even say whatever if I were to
just to come by Lionheart Jiu Jitsu just
cold come by when you're there how would
I be treated great dude you better give
me the best seat in the house what do I
get I give you a bottle of water
probably if you didn't have one but then
I might make a comment of like how can
you have a bottle of water you're gonna
come work out you don't have no water
dude what would I see you doing if I
were to come by like 8 P.M probably
horsing around with some boys dude with
some of the guys
yeah horsing around with some boys that
doesn't sound very good in 2000 yeah
that's really how it goes like you guys
just there's no like structure to like
okay you guys from nine to ten we're
gonna do arm box oh no no we teach class
so like somebody will be Joe our
professor blackball Joe teodoro yeah
he's cool he's the man he'll be uh Pride
teaching something and I'll be on the
sidelines arson around with some other
boys
age-appropriate boys
because that's funny like if you were to
like if I was doing a practice session
and you would have dropped by it would
100 be horsing around no structure we
mess we'd probably be drilling we might
be doing some Jiu Jitsu or something we
might be locked in do you have a guy at
the gym that doesn't horse around and
when you guys watch around he just sits
there and waits for you to finish yeah
[Laughter]
I'll be teaching class and then I'll be
like am I talking too much
and I'm like sorry I'm talking let's
let's just go it's a good lesson
to like do the real [__] yeah and you
know that guy's mad like inside he's
like dude I'm wasting my money one day I
want to get so good I'm gonna just
destroy that horse around me
no but uh no we know how to who to mess
around with we know who to like be
serious I mean which boys to mess around
with yeah we know you should just have
them around like Richard
when they fill up their form when they
join there should be a like you know
those check boxes where it's like check
if you're Hispanic or not
are you comfortable with horseplay
before yes
[Applause]
dude would you mind interview like your
close friends going to uh your school
and like taking lessons from you or do
you think that'll be too nah I try to
tell some of my my best man at my
wedding I'm actually he uh he signed up
but he stopped coming so I text him
every day I'm like where the [__] are
you dude and he's like it's not for me
and I was like stop being a [__] not
for some people that's what they tell
themselves oh but you guys don't say
that now if you want to do it look if
there's never been a person that comes
to it and you guys just have to
collectively go
Eric assistant you're saying the cool
thing about Jutsu is like I've seen the
most unathletic dudes who are the most
physically incapable of doing anything
do well as Jitsu oh everyone yeah
everybody sucks at the beginning but
you're supposed to it's like that by
Design but over time you'll get better
but it's also like
you have to just put yourself in a
situation where like you get beat up you
know what I mean so a lot of people
don't really like that so then they feel
like oh this isn't the norm for me this
is uncomfortable yeah something they
don't want to do it all right but it's
like when you buy the ghee you get the
[__] pajamas you get all the uh you
know wow top three the reasons why
someone would be kicked out of a
Jiu-Jitsu gym
not enough horseplay dude not enough
horses around would you get okay let's
say that I was there right now and then
we're rolling yeah and I get frustrated
because I can't [__] do it and I just
start sucking [__] out of your face yeah
you might get it [__]
you'll get thrown you might get promoted
holy [__]
they'll just add strikes
that's actually happened to me I like
what he did
someone starts talking yeah this is at
our old MMA gym fight Academy during
practice he was like a guy who was a
boxer and like I wasn't good at Jiu
Jitsu the time I was like still starting
off and this guy was like a boxer he was
like a pro boxer and he started like
doing Jiu Jitsu and then I think I don't
unders I don't know if he just didn't
know what the rules were
yeah but I'm telling you it was a wild
time it was a wild time so he started
punching me in the face oh like was
barely hard just started punching me did
you tell me how was dude you don't know
how funny I am bro I was such a young
lad right I just was like oh I didn't
say anything and I just was like all
right I'm gonna try to [__] kill this
guy like so I was just gonna like we
were kind of fighting so that I did it
but I didn't punch him back oh like a
freaking [__] I should have punched him
back did you break his arm did he tap
out nah I just remember we just finished
the round and then we just moved like I
just didn't say anything and I was like
dude [__] that guy
you didn't speak to him yeah
and he was like he was he would go to
the gym a lot and I was like all right
next time every time I train with him I
just have to know that he might just not
follow the rules
I mean it probably doesn't look like it
if you guys are getting raped and he's
going like this yeah
technique I'm here's what his side of
the story is yeah you know sometimes I
think about it to this day like I'll be
in the shower and I'll just think about
it that's right his story is probably
like I just I saw his face and I just
had to stop it like this this little
Chinese dude kept trying to horse around
with me yeah
I'll say this I did have a body type and
I still kind of do where I'm really easy
to like like oh I have a punchable face
in my life but also too in a way of like
you could really be probably get away
so you have the body type of being
bullied yeah yeah for sure for sure